[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلن جيش الفتح سيطرته على معاقل
النظام السوري التي تفصل بين ريف ادلب
والساحل السوري ومنطقه سهل الغاب بريف
حماه في الوقت الذي فيه حزب الله عن
سيطرته على كامل جبال فليطه سوريه في
منطقه القلمون نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه
في
محورين هل تواصل المعارضه تقدمها نحو
الساحل ام تتجه لدمشق ام لمناطق
اخرى هل يؤثر تقدم حزب الله في القلمون
على قوات المعارضه غرب
سوريا
بسيطره جيش الفتح على حاجز المعصره الواقع
بين بلدتي محبل وافريكا اخر معاقل النظام
التي تفصل بين ريف ادلب والساحل السوري
ومنطقه سهل الغاب بريف حماه تكون امام
قوات المعارضه عده اهداف يجب عليها
الاختيار بدقه فيما بينها وغير بعيد عنها
في منطقه سهل الغاب يحشد النظام قواته
التي يقال انها مدعومه بالالاف من عناصر
حزب الله والحرس الثوري الايراني
والمقاتلين العراقيين الشيعه وفي القلمون
قرب الحدود اللبنانيه اعلن حزب الله
سيطرته على كامل جبال فليطه السوريه في
خطوه يرى البعض انها لن تؤثر على الوضع
الميداني تتضح استراتيجيه المعارضه واهداف
حروبها الاخيره وتتوضح تتجه في راي احد
قادتها الى قلب النظام في الساحل والى
راسه في دمشق في الساحل وجواره لم تعد
المعارك في ادلب بل تجاوزتها ثمه تقدم على
الطريق بين اللاذقيه واريحا هناك يتكبد
النظام خسائر فادحه والى هناك يتردد ان
الاف المقاتلين الايرانيين وقيل انهم من
الحرس الثوري ومئات العراقيين من
الميليشيات الشيعيه توجهوا بهدف شن هجوم
مضاد يحول دون تقدم جيش الفتح باتجاه
الساحل وفي راي كثيرين فان خزان الاسد
البشري في منطقه الساحل اكثر هشاشه مما
يظن واقل مناعه مما يروج فثم تذمر تصاعد
في اوساط العلويين هناك من النظام ومن شان
تقدم المعارضه ودخولها تلك المناطق مسنوده
بخطاب سياسي مطمئن ان يحيد مناصري الاسد
على الاقل ويعزلهم عما توصف بمساعي الاسد
الى توريط الجميع في حربه كي يبقى تعطف
على هذا معطيات تتشكل في المنطقه قد تقلب
المعادله راسا على عقب وعلى خلاف ما يامل
الاسد فقطع الطريق على خطته المرجا للبقاء
باقامه ما يشبه الدويله على الشريط
الساحلي لا يحتاج سوى الى قرار دولي فاقل
تبدو هذه الخطه انتحاريه بتداعيات كارثيه
على الجوار التركي كما انها تثير حفيظه بل
رفض دول الجوار التي قد تنتقل اليها حم
التقسيم على اسس طائفيه ورغم التاكيدات
الايرانيه للاسد بان طهران لن تتخلى عنه
فان سيناريو لوزان وجنيف قد يدفع
الايرانيين لمعارض سيناريو التقسيم لصالح
انتقال محتمل للسلطه يحفظ مصالحهم قلب
النظام مريض اذا في الساحل ومث خن بالجراح
اما راسه في دمشق فثم من يدافع عنه اكثر
من النظام نفسه حسن نصر الله الذي يعتبر
بقاء الاسد معركه حياه او موت بدا في
القلمون استراتيجيه مضاده هدفها الابعد
قطع الطريق على المعارضه لتتواصل جغرافيا
من الشمال الى الجنوب فوسط البلاد على ان
ذلك غير كاف ومضلل كما يؤكد معارضون فخي
نصر الله نفسه مربوطه بطهران وثمه من اصبح
يجهر بالحديث عن تصعيد في اللغه يلجا اليه
الرجل قد يجعل من تراجع طهران صعبا لا باس
من استبعاده ولو على مراحل كما المحت
وتلمح بعض
التسريبات لمناقشه موضوع حلقتنا ينضم
الينا من اسطنبول هشام مروه نائب رئيس
الائتلاف الوطني السوري المعارض من عمان
العميد اسعد الزعبي الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ومن بيروت الياس فرحات
العميد المتقاعد والمحلل السياسي
والاستراتيجي اهلا بضيوفي الكرام ابدا
بضيفي من عمان العميد اسعد الزعبي الان
امامي الخارطه والسؤال الخطوه القادمه ل
المعارضه باي اتجاه الساحل الى حلب الى
حماه الى حمص ما هي الخطوه القادمه
برايك بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم مساء الخير
لك ولضيوفك الكرام لا شك ان ما حصل اليوم
في ادلب من انتصار ل ثوار المنطقه
الشماليه يسجل يعني ك من انصع هذه الصفحات
صفحات تاريخ الثوره السوريه لانه ياتي
بعيد اعلان حسن نصر الله عن الاستنفار
العام او النفير العام للشيعه في لبنان
كما ياتي ايضا بعد التهديدات الايرانيه
والوعود الايرانيه بارسال المزيد من
العناصر الشيعيه والعناصر المرتزقه من
ايران الى النظام مع ان هناك ملاحظه كان
يجب ان ينتبه اليها خاصه الموالين للنظام
او العلويون عندما علموا ان 7000 مرتزق
ايراني سوف يصلون لحمايه دمشق يعني لحمايه
كرسي النظام وليس لحمايه المنطقه الساحليه
ورغم ذلك هناك سجل انتصارا كبيرا للثوار
وبالتالي الان يمكن القول يعني افها
بالكامل الان العميد اسعد ماذا عن سؤالي
ماذا عن الخطوه القادمه نعم نؤ نعم نعم
نعم من المفترض ان تكون الخطوه القادمه
باتجاه المنطقه الممتده من غرب حماه والتي
تقع ما بين نصف او منتصف سال الغاب
وباتجاه المنطقه الساحليه وهنا انا اؤكد
ان التعامل مع هذه المنطقه الجغرافيه من
المفترض ان يتم بعاملين العامل
الاسكرينا الذي يترافق مع عامل سياسي يجب
ان يكون هناك رسائل سياسيه للموج الموالين
الموجودين في المنطقه الساحليه وايضا
للقرى الموجوده غربي حماه والتي تعتبر هي
يعني اساس القرى الموالي النظام ولذا انا
اعتقد تماما ان هناك سوف يتم عمل عسكري
جماعي يتالف من ثوار ادلب المتجهين باتجاه
سال الغاب من الشمال وكذلك ثوار شمال حماء
او ريف حماء الشمالي مع ريف حماء الشمالي
الغربي ولذلك هذه العمليه العسكريه سوف
تكون عمل عمليه جيده عمليه ضاغطه على
النظام ايضا يجب ان تترافق مع ضغط من
الفرقه الساحليه او الثوار في المنطقه
الساحليه وهنا اؤكد تماما ان العمل
الهجومي في المنطقه الساحليه اهم او او
يعني اهون على الثوار او اقل يعني يعني
تعبا على الثوار من المفترض ان ان يبداوا
فيه ولذلك اعتقد اليوم ان الثوار يخططون
الى عمل يستهدف المنطقه الغربيه من قرى
حماء او ريف حماء وكذلك برايك الخطوه
القادمه تستهدف الساحل وليس دمشق وهنا
اسال ليفي من بيروت الياس العميد الياس
فرحات تركيز النظام لقواته مدعومه بعناصر
من الحرس الثوري الايراني بعرص من حزب
الله وايضا حديث عن ميليشيات شيعيه وافغان
الى ذلك في منطقه سهل الغاب في حماه هل
تعتقد بان الخط الطوه القادمه المعركه
القادمه سوف تتركز في هذه المنطقه في حماه
في سهل الغاب
تحديدا يعني هناك ثلاثه احتمالات لتحرك
قوات المعارضه السوريه الاحتمال الاول
والثاني هو تقوم به تنظيم القاعده في بلاد
الشام المعروف بجبهه
النصره اما بالهجوم جنوبا باتجاه سهل
الغاب وحما او غربا باتجاه جبال اللادقيه
لكن مثل ه هذا القرار الكبير الهجوم جنوبا
او شمالا لا يستطيع ابو محمد الجولاني
اتخاذه بل هو يرجع الى الدكتور ايمن
ظواهري زعيم تنظيم القاعده الذي هو لديه
الاتصالات ويمده بالمقاتلين وبجميع انواع
المدد وهو الذي يحركه استراتيجيا لا لم
يعرف بعد ما اذا كانت ظواهري بصدد الدخول
الى سهل الغاب ام الى الساحل الاحتمال
الثالث هو التنظيم الاكبر في المعارضه
السوريه وهو داعش الذي سيحتل تدمر وباديه
الشام ومستعد للهجوم على محافظه السويداء
وانا اعتقد انني ارجح ان تقوم المعارضه
الممثله بداعش بالهجوم على محافظه
السويداء فتقلب الاوراق داخل سوريا وفي
المنطقه
بكاملها ضيفي من اسطنبول هشام مروه عن
دائما عن الخطوه القادمه ولكن ربما من
ناحيه
ا سياسيه الاتجاه باتجاه الساحل او باتجاه
دمشق ماذا عن الحسابات في هاتين النقطتين
وايهما اول ك خطوه
قادمه
ا مساء الخير لك وخوه المشاهدين ولضيوفك
الكرام يعني فقط اريد ان اصحح ما جاء في
حديث ضيفك من بيروت القضيه ليست جبهه
النصره هو جيش الفتح واختزال القوى التي
تقاتل النظام في ادلب وفي شمال سوريا
باحدى المنظمات هذا امر بالتاكيد غير صحيح
ايضا لا الظواهر ولا غير الظواهري قادر ان
يتخذ قرار تلتزم به المعارضه السوريه التي
تقاتل في سوريا فهذا خارج اطار حسبانه
ومرفوض من قبل قوى الثوره السوريه بكل
تاكيد داعش المعارضه نعتبرها نعم داعش
ايضا ليست من المعارضه وايض ان نصحح هذا
المفهوم بالنسبه لخط يعني اريد ان اقول
ياتي تحرك المعارضه هنا في الشمال وفي
الجنوب وفي كل مكان من سوريا باتجاه هدف
استراتيجي وهدف تكتيكي اما الهدف
الاستراتيجي فهو فعلا دفع النظام للحل
السياسي نحن لسنا حريصين على القتل ولا
على استمرار القتل وعلى لا كسب اراضي
يريدنا النظام ان يفهم انه ليس هناك فرصه
لحل عسكري لا ان جاءت قوات 7000 شخص من
ايران او من غيرها نحن نعلم تمام العلم ان
ان بشار الاسد يريد ان يقاتل حتى اخر جندي
ايراني وحتى اخر جندي من حزب الله وليس
حتى وكل ذلك من اجل ان يبقى في السلطه من
اجل وهذا امر واضح منسبه للمعارضه
السياسيه والمعارضه العسكريه المطلوب الان
تكتيكيا باتجاه العسكري لا بد من الرسائل
واضحه للساحل السوري من انه جزء من عمليه
الثوره وجزء من عمليه التغيير وليس محسوبا
على النظام ما يجري في الساحل من معلومات
تصلنا من اخواننا هناك انهم فعلا يتململون
من النظام ويعتبرون انه يضحي بهم في
بروباجندا للاسف غير مقبوله على الاطلاق
بالنسبه للشعب السوري ايضا التحرك باتجاه
الغاب او باتجاه الجنوب للوصول الى دمشق
هذا قرار كما تعلم تكتيكي ميداني يحدده
الظروف ولكن المطلوب هو رساله سياسيه لن
يحسم الامر لن يستطيع النظام حسم المساله
عسكريا قوه الثوره قادره على المواجهه
قادره على الاستمرار قادره على تشكيل
الخطر لا ليس له امام في هذه الظروف الا
ان يقبر بالحل السياسي وان يفهم حلفائه
ومن وراءه انه لا يمكن لهم ان يبقوا او ان
يبقوا الاسد في السلطه الى ما لا نهايه
طيب العميد اسعد فيما يتعلق باتخاذ الخطوه
بالتحرك باتجاه الساحل او باتجاه دمشق
ودعني اركز على مساله الساحل هل هذا فقط
يخضع لحسابات الثوار في الميدان ام ان
هناك ايضا حسابات دوليه يجب ان توضع في
الحسبان عندما يتم اتخاذ القرار بهذا
الاتجاه اي الاتجاه نحو
الساحل لا شك ان هناك حسابات دوليه وهذه
الحسابات كانت مؤثره بمرحله ما خاصه في
معركه الانفال ولذلك يعني الجيش الحر ثوار
سوريه عندما تحر حرروا منطقه كسب ثم
تابعوا طريقهم باتجاه اللاذقيه ظهرت هناك
العديد من الضغوط الدوليه وبالتالي رج عاد
الثوار الى نقطه البدايه هذا يعني ما يؤرق
الثوار وانا اريد هنا ان اصحح ايضا ما
تحدث به ضيفك قبل قليل هم ثوار سوريا لا
يوجد بينهم كما يقال يعني كلام لايمن
الظواهري انما هذه شماعه اتخذها حسن نصر
الله من اجل الدفع بعشرات الالاف من
الميليشيا ال الشيعيه باتجاه سوريا ثم عن
داعش داعش لا يمكن ان تهاجم السويداء الا
اذا اراد النظام ذلك لان داعش هي ربيبه
النظام هو يمكن ان يضغط بها على السويداء
ولكن يعلم تماما ان اهل السويداء جهازين
دفاع هنا ايضا فقط كلمه واحده بما يتعلق
بالمنطقه الساحليه اقول لك ربما الثوار لا
يهاجمون الساحل بكامل الساحل سوف يحاولون
الضغط على المنطقه الساحليه من الشمال من
جهه جبل الاكراد والتركمان ولكن ايضا لابد
من الضغط على ريف حماء الغربي لانهم يعني
موضع يعني قلق وموضع اعتداءات على القرى
ال المحاذي لحماه وبالتالي الوصول الى
مطار حماه لا يمكن الوصول الى مطار حماء
الا من خلال هذا الممر المتمثل بتلك القرى
طيب هذا عن الاماكن التي تفرض فيها او
للمعارضه القدره على المبادره باعتبارها
هي من تتقدم في هذه الاماكن ماذا عما يحدث
في القلمون وتاثير ما يجري في القلمون على
مجمل الخارطه او تصور لاي سيناريو قادم في
الايام القادمه بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش خيارات قوات المعارضه السوريه بعد
انتصاراتها الاخيره والتطورات الميدانيه
في منطقه القلمون واوجد تحيه لضيوفي في
هذه الحلقه العميد الياس فرحات ضيفي من
بيروت الى اي مدى حسابات حزب الله في
القلمون قد تؤثر فعلا على اي تقدم
للمعارضه سواء في منا مناطق قريبه من
القلمون او حتى في مناطق مثل حلب وغيرها
بشكل او
باخر قبل ان اجيب على سؤالك دعني الفه نظر
ضيفك الكريم الى ان السيد ابو محمد
الجولاني ظهر على شاشتكم الكريمه منذ ايام
واعلن ولاءه وطاعته للدكتور ايمن ظواهري
زعيم تنظيم القاعده والجولاني هو زعيم
تنظيم القاعده في بلاد الشام جبهه النصره
وهي الفصيل الاساسي والاكبر في منطقه ادلب
وو
و متور بشكل اوخر دا سور هو يعلن علنا نعم
نعم لا لا هذا هذا لا يبغي ذلك
يعني لكي نضع النقاط على الحروف القاط على
الحروف هو ولاؤه لايمن ظواهري ولا اعتقد
انه يقوم باي هجوم اما غربا او جنوبا الا
بقرار واشاره من الدكتور ايمن الظواهري
اعود الى سؤالك حول موضوع القلمون موضوع
القلمون يعني لم يحسم بشكل نها نهائي بعد
هناك بعض الجيوب لتنظيم القاعده في بلاد
الشام في جرود عرسال وهناك تنظيم داعش
الذي يتمركز في جرود الجراجير وقاره ويبدو
ان الصدام بين داعش وحزب الله بات وشيكا
وخلال الايام المقبله اي هذه المعركه هي
تريح لبنان من السيارات المفخخه التي
ارسلها داعش وتنظيم
النصره تنظيم جبهه القاعده في بلاد الشام
المعروف بالنص اعيد سؤالي العميد الياس
فقط اعيد سؤالي نبقى في الشق العسكري
والحسابات العسكريه برايك ما هي حسابات
حزب الله فيما يفعله في القلمون بالنظر
الى مجمل المعطيات في الجبهات في
سوريا
ا اذا اذا استطاع حزب الله حسم وضع
القلمون بكامله ولم يعد هناك تواجد لتنظيم
القاعده ولا لداعش في القلمون فذلك يريح
الحزب في لبنان ويجعل الحدود اللبنانيه
سوريا مفتوحه امام حزب الله وامام الجيش
السوري وهذا يريح السوريين من الجهه
الاخرى على جبهات اخرى لا ادري ما هي
اولوياتهم الان ال لان المبادره اليوم هي
بيد تنظيم القاعده في بلاد الشام وبيد
داعش وليست بيد الجيش السوري لانه في حاله
دفاع في هذه الايام السيد هشام مروه ضيفي
من اسطنبول هل ما يفعله حزب الله في
القلمون كما يرى البعض ويحل البعض انه
يدخل في اطار حسابات الدوله البديله دوله
الساحل في حال ما اذا الامور افضت الى
محاصره الاسد ونظامه في هذا الشريط
الساحلي ليس فقط الموضوع هو موضوع البحث
او حمايه الاسد من اجل الانسحاب الى شريط
ساحلي هم يصرحون باكثر من ذلك هم يقولون
سندافع عنه بالاضافه الى الجنود القادمين
المشبع بالحقد الطائفي من ايران ومن
العراق من اجل ان يدافعوا في جث الشغور
وفي ادلب وفي دمشق وفي في حلب يعني هم
قادمون من اجل معاركه انقاذ النظام وليس
من معركه فقط من اجل تامين ملاذ امن
التقسيم بالنسبه للسوريين وحتى يعني لا
ابالغ حتى بالنسبه للاخوه في جبال الساحل
مرفوض تماما تجارب التقسيم ستفشل ولو
رعتها دول ولو رعتها قوى كما تعلم سوريا
تجاوزت ازمه التقسيم في مطلع القرن العش
ومع ذلك لم يكن لم تكن بهذا الوعي السياسي
الموجود في هذه المرحله لا اريد ان اكون
ايضا كثير التشاؤم او كثير التفاؤل وجود
حزب الله وجود ايران وجود كل القوى
الداعمه للاسد لن تؤثر على مسيره الثوره
سيتجه الثوار في الداخل الثوار ليس فقط في
الساحل وهم في الشمال وهم يتقدمون بالنسبه
للجنوب هم موجودون في القلمون ايضا هم
موجودون في الغوطه ايضا موجودون في درعا
ايضا بالنسبه للقلم السيطره التي يدعيها
حزب الله لا تغني ولا تسمن من جوع هي نقاط
لا يمكن لاحد ان يتمسك بها ولذلك القوه
الثوريين السور سوريين الان يتجهون باتجاه
معركه الكر والفر اي مهاجمه مراكز تمركز
النظام وهذا اسهل عليهم من الحفاظ على هذه
المناطق من اجل ذلك اقول حزب الله وما
يعمله في في في جبال فليطه او في القلمون
لن يؤثر بل على العكس سيحول وجوده الى
اهداف ثابته للقوى السوريه العسكريه
الثوريه من اجل ان فع النقطه مساله تقدم
حزب الله في القلمون وما مدى امكانيه
تاثيره على الحسابات سواء ان كانت بالتوجه
الى دمشق او الى منطقه الساحل العميد اسعد
الى اي مدى يؤثر هذه السيطره من قبل حزب
الله على القلمون او تقدمه في القلمون حتى
الان على هذين المعطي سواء كان التجه الى
دمشق او الى
الساحل سيدي الكريم هناك قراءه عسكريه
خاطئه لمنطقه القلمون ا يعني القلمون فيه
حوالي خمس او ست مدن كبيره قاره ودير عطيه
والنبك ويبرود ورنكس هذه هذه المدن
بالكامل هي تحت سيطره النظام يوجد فيها
عشرات الحواجز للنظام وحزب الله
والمليشيات العراقيه انما ثوار موجودين في
الجبال في الجرود يقاتلون بطريقه
الاستنزاف يقاتلون بطريقه الكر وفر
يحاولون ان يحملوا النظام والعناصر
والمليشيات المرتزقه العديد من الخسائر
ويعني كما يلاحظ الاعلام يعني اعلامكم وكل
اعلام يعني ينقل يوميا مقتل عشرات الفطاس
من حزب الله ومن الاحزاب التي تقاتل معه
واليوم نشاهد حتى الحزب الشيوعي اللبناني
دخل على فط يعلم الجميع ان حسن نصر الله
هو الخادم الامين والمنفذ لسياسه ايران
وبالتالي يعني لا يعني من الخطا ان نقول
ان نتهم الجولاني ولكن حقيقه ما يقوم به
نصر الله هو عباره عن خادم ومنفذ لسياسه
ايران في سوريا انما عندما نتحدث عن تقدم
لحزب الله فمن الناحيه العسكريه هذا غير
منطقي غير صحيح لا يمكن العمل به عباره عن
يعني فبركه او بروباجندا اعلاميه ليس اكثر
من ذلك هناك العديد من الهجمات التي نفذها
حزب الله خلال 15 يوما على طله موسى او
طلعه موسى استطاع ان يسيطر على تله فيها
تسمى يعني التله الاولى او التله
الصغيره حاول تصوير عدد من الافلام اذا
عندما نقول احتلال او لا لا يوجد تقدم او
احتلال النظام ما زال يسيطر على مناطق
القلمون فيه يعني حواجز لحزب الله لكن ما
ما ما ينفذه الثور حقيقه الان هو يعني لب
العلم العسكري وهو تحميل حزب الله العديد
من الخسائر ولذلك اعلن النفير حسن نصر
الله وكذلك سوف ت
تلك يعني الميليشيات اللبنانيه التي تقاتل
معه ايضا سوف تعل النفير وهنا بمنسبه
المعركه ما بين حزب الله وداعش عفوا دقيقه
دقيقه بس المعركه ما بين داعش وحزب الله
وحزب الله وحزب الله لا يوجد معركه هناك
اتفاق ضمن ما بين حزب الله وداعش لتسهيل
مرور عناصر حزب الله للداخل وكذلك عناصر
النظام السوري ما الذي بقي للنظام السوري
حتى لا يلجا الى الجلوس لطاوله التفاوض
بدون ان يرى نفسه في موقع افضل الان ينحصر
بشكل جغرافي حسب اضع الخيط امامنا ينحصر
الى مناطق معينه ما الذي يمنعه من الجلوس
الى التفاوض بشكل حقيقي هذه
المره لا ادري ما هو القرار السياسي الذي
اتخذه النظام السوري ان كان صحيحا انه
يرفض الجلوس او ان له شروب معينه او ان له
حسابات اخرى حتى الان لا يوجد عمليه
مفاوضه جديه يعني مع عمليه موسكو واحد
وموسكو اثنين لم تكن عمليه يعني جديه سوى
عمليه اختباريه لا اكثر ولا اقل اما ما
يحكى عن
مفاوضات يعني الموضوع عند مستوره الوسيط
الدولي هو الذي يعرف من يرفض ولماذا يرفض
اذا كان النظام هو اللي يرفض او اذا كانت
المعارضه ثم ان الجلوس مع المعارضه مع
احترامنا وتقديرنا لشخصياتها السياسيه لا
يقدم ولا تخ ولا يؤخر على الارض لان على
الارض من يجب ان يجلس على الطاوله هو من
الموجود على الارض اذا جاء الدكتور ايمن
الظواهري وابو بكر البغدادي وفوضوا النظام
الاسد يمكن ان نجد حلا لان هؤلاء هم
المعارضون على الارض اما الاخوه المعارضون
في في يعني باقي الدول فهم معارضون
سياسيون يعني لهم ارائهم التي يعني يختلف
الناس في لكن ليس لهم علاقه والدليل انهم
عندما حاولوا عندما عن عندما حاولوا ان
ياتوا الى ادلب منعهم ايمن الظواهري وا
محمد الجولاني من القدوم الى ادلب وبقيوا
حيث هم في الدول و كان هذا ليس جوابا على
هي ان هشام مروه فيما يتعلق بايجاد حل
سياسي في ظل المعطيات العسكريه الحاليه
الان ماذا عن تصور مقبل الايام
برايك لا بد لنا ان نجد انفسنا ايضا
النظام وكل من يقف وراءه بعد فشل الحل
العسكري لابد ان نجد انفسنا امام الحل
السياسي بوجود هذا التقدم من القوه
الثوريه الثوريه الثوريه وليس على الاطلاق
قوى القاعده او قوى الارهاب اطلاقا اتحدث
عن معارضه سوريه سياسيه مرتبطه بالقوى
العسكريه ليس هناك انفصال كما يريد او كما
يشير الى ذلك ضيفك من لبنان هالكلام غير
صحيح على الاطلاق السياسيون هنا يمثلون
الذين يقاتلون على الارض وهم قادرون فعلا
على ان يمثلهم والامر بيننا عندما تاتي
مفاوضات نعم نتجه باتجاه حل سياسي ولكن
عندما يقتنع النظام انه لا يمكن له ان ي
ان ان يحسم المساله عسكريا وهذا متوقف على
اتوقع على هذه المرحله او العمليه الاخيره
التي يقوم بها من خلال هذا الحشد يعني انا
متفائل ان تكون هذه المعارك العسكريه اخر
ما يمكن ان يكون من نزيه الدم في سوريا
وان نتجه الى الحل السياسي كما تعلم
المعارضه مستعده للحل السياسي مستعده ل
فعلا باطارات علميه ومهنيه ت تضمن وجود
حقيقي لسوريا مستقبل سوريا حره بعيده عن
الاستبداد والفساد يتحقق فيها دوله
المواطنه والعداله للجميع العيد اسعد يد
ان اكد هنا تفضل نعم لا تفضل بسؤالك لعلي
اجيب على الاثنين مع لا سؤالي موجه للعميد
اسعد الزعبي فيما يتعلق ب طيب في
نعمق الحديث تفضل بكل تاكيد من خلال
لقاءاتنا مع المبعوثين الدوليين وعلى
الاخص مع السيد ديمستورا واضح تماما لنا
ان المزاج الدولي اصبح مقتنعا انه لا يمكن
اقت الارهاب بدون ان يتم انجاز الحل
السياسي في سوريا
هذه من عمان العميد اسعد الزعب فيما يتعلق
ب ما الذي اختلف دوليا حتى يرى لتقدم
المعارضه على اساس انه
باتجاه فرض امر واقع جديد تكون فيه الكلمه
العليا للمعارضه وليس
للنظام لان يعني بشار الاسد على اعتباره
له جاهل بالسياسه وبالامس كان يقاد من
ايران او من موسكو ولذلك الان العالم
باسره بدا يدرك تماما ان نظام نهار لا
يوجد نظام هناك ميليشيات ايرانيه تقاتل في
سوريا عندما يتم الجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات من المفترض ان يجلس الخامنئي
كما يجلس بوتين كما يجلس حصن نصر الله
وليس بشار الاسد الان تصريحات الامريكيه
والغربيه والبريطانيه اصبحت واضحه تماما
انه يجب من اجل يعني درء الارهاب ومجل
محاربه الارهاب يجب محاربه الاسد اولا
لانه هو اساس الارهاب في المنطقه حقيقه
بداك الجمع العميد اشكرك واعتذر منك اسعد
الزعبي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كما
اشكر ضيفي من بيروت الياس فرحات العميد
المتقاعد والمحلل السياسي والاستراتيجي
وكذلك ضيفي من اسطنبول هشام مروه نائب
رئيس الائتلاف الوطني السوري المعارض بذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء باذن
الله
[موسيقى]
ن